und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und marietta slomka im
juni nach mallorca und die insel ist
leer
ein eigentlich unerfüllbarer traum doch
corona macht's möglich
rund 10.000 auserwählte so darf man sie
wohl nennen die auch die anreise per
vollgepackte flugzeug nicht schreckt
dürfen ab heute probeweise wieder auf
die insel bevor es ab dem 21
juni mit dem tourismus wieder richtig
losgeht soll und die glückliche vorhut
besteht nur aus deutschen touristen die
auf einem der balearen flieger gebucht
waren die jetzt zugelassen wurden
im moment können noch nicht einmal
festland spanier kommen das ganze dürfte
eine ziemlich einmalige aktion sein an
die sich die reisenden wohl ihr leben
lang erinnern werden weißt du noch
damals auf mallorca als wir die strände
für uns hatten
dort beginnt dominique löschmeister
seinen bericht über reisen in zeiten von
corona deutsche touristen auf dem weg
nach mallorca besetzt bis auf den
letzten platz sind die flieger maske ist
pflicht abstand unmöglich am flughafen
in palma messen wärmebildkameras die
körpertemperatur die deutschen test
touristen sind die ersten die wieder
nach mallorca reisen dürfen vorher
geplant
es wurde mehrfach abgesagt und erst saß
minute noch mal gebucht und wir sind von
dem von dem sicherheitsprojekte oder
konzept selber zeug gestartet waren die
urlauber heute morgen unter anderem vom
frankfurter flughafen dort hoffen sie
darauf dass die deutschen wieder mehr
fliegen im mai zählte deutschlands
größter flughafen 95 prozent weniger
passagiere heute bis zumindest etwas
mehr los
wir haben hier die notwendigen
abstandsregelungen die
hygienevorschriften die werde umgesetzt
haben und natürlich eben auch inzwischen
die masken pflicht eingeführt doch je
mehr menschen wieder fliegen umso voller
werden die jets kein problem sagen die
fluggesellschaften die luft selber im
flugzeug ist so rein wie in einem
operationssaal sie wird alle drei
minuten ausgetauscht und durch
sogenannte hepa filter komplett
gereinigt
ein chor ohne restrisiko bestehe aber
auch im flugzeug sagen experten die
airlines wollen die maschinen voll
besetzen auch verkehrsmittel wie die
bahn verzichten auf abstand setzen auf
den mund nasenschutz die urlauber seien
zurückkommen dabei warten viele noch
immer auf die erstattung stornierte
flugtickets sonja krause und peter
stolze wollten im märz nach florida
die lufthansa stornierte wegen corona
den flug auf das geld warten sie seit
wochen
ich finds halt nicht sehr
kundenfreundlich und man möchte ja auch
wieder buchung bei der lufthansa oder
bei anderen 30 gesellschaften ich finde
es halt mal wird das er in stich
gelassen nach eu-recht müssten die
airlines die tickets erstatten es geht
um klagen von tausenden kunden nicht nur
gegen die lufthansa es trifft alle
flugpassagiere gleich und auch alle
airlines arbeiten eigentlich gleich mit
dieser schweige taktik und lassen den
kunden zunächst einmal im regen stehen
die lufthansa versprach inzwischen jedem
kunden seinen ticketpreis zu erstatten
denn die urlauber sollen wieder buchen
und ins flugzeug steigen
mit großer begeisterung jedenfalls
wurden auf mallorca die ersten deutschen
touristen heute empfangen
mallorca macht wieder auf und auch nach
frankreich und in die schweiz ist jetzt
wieder alles komplett offen als sei
nichts gewesen aber das stimmt so
natürlich nicht
die wochen in denen plötzlich die
schlagbäume wieder runter gingen haben
spuren hinterlassen es gab frustrationen
und sogar nationalistische
feindseligkeiten die nachwirken
aber auch die erkenntnis wie eng man in
diesem europa zusammen lebt und wie viel
schaden anrichten wenn sie mitten durch
einen gemeinsamen lebensraum für albas
berg war für uns in konstanz im märz
hatte deutschland hier quasi über nacht
einen bauzaun zum schweizer kreuzlingen
errichtet seit mitte mai waren die
kontrollen gelockert worden aber
wirklich abgebaut wurden die
absperrungen erst heute nacht mit der
grenze kann auch matthäus schulz seinen
kiosk nach drei monaten wieder aufmachen
er ist wie so viele einzelhändler hier
in konstanz angewiesen auf seine
schweizer stampfen
wir haben dann auch tricks versucht
trotzdem offen zu halten
aber das hat sich dann schlussendlich
nicht gerechnet so blieb uns dann
tatsächlich ende märz nichts anderes
übrig als wie zu schließen und jetzt
wieder zu öffnen
das war eine harte zeit klar die schweiz
ist nur ein paar meter entfernt von dem
kiosk aber wegen corona war die grenze
dicht
jetzt kann wieder jeder durch auch ohne
sogenannten triftigen grund für die
schweizer heißt das günstiger einkaufen
auf deutscher seite geht wieder und lily
brett breitschwert kann jetzt ganz legal
familie und freunde besuchen hier an der
grenze ist es einfach ganz normal dass
man jeden tag teilweise mehrfach hin und
her läuft das war schon eine massive
einschränkung vor allem hier an der
grünen grenze die vor corona seit
jahrzehnten gefühlt keine grenze mehr
war rechts kreuzlingen in der schweiz
und links konstanz in deutschland über
wochen trennte der bauzaun die
eigentlich längst zusammengewachsen
städte um selbst schweizerisch deutsche
paare durften sich nur durch die
gitterstäbe sehen das war ganz ein
einschneidendes erlebnis als auf einmal
diese grenzen zu wahren und hier noch
dieser zaun stand bauten wurden wir
wirklich die bevölkerung von kreuzlingen
konstanz wurden da auseinander gerissen
die beiden stadtoberhäupter sind sich
deshalb einig die strikte
grenzschließung hier war ein fehler der
nicht noch einmal gemacht werden darf
ich habe persönlich schon erinnerung an
die 80er jahre an die raf zeiten als die
schweizer grenze zum teil sehr scharf
bewacht worden ist und für uns das
überqueren der grenze in die tägliche
erfahrung war und ich habe immer gesagt
unsere jugendlichen unsere jungen
erwachsenen die tausende von menschen
die hier studieren die kennen das gar
nicht mehr
die sind damit aufgewachsen und das
einzige gute was vielleicht dieser zaun
gehabt er war bewusst zu machen
dort ist eine grenze und wenn man diese
grenze schließt und das geht von heute
auf morgen
dann muss man große mühen unternehmen um
sie wieder zu öffnen deshalb fordern sie
hier das auch bei einer möglichen
zweiten pandemiewelle die grenze offen
bleiben muss
der finanzielle und emotionale schaden
für die bodenseeregion sei zu groß
infektionsschutz müsse auch ohne grenzen
gehen
insgesamt gibt es für reisende noch
einiges zu beachten welche regeln für
einreise und aufenthalt in verschiedenen
ländern gelten finden sie in einer
übersicht auf zdf heute ja die einen
freuen sich dass die grenzen endlich
wieder aufgehen wohingegen sich die
praxis briten auf die abschottung vollen
aber was heißt schon die briten in
dieser frage ist das land nach wie vor
gespalten nun dass die unterlegenen
wechselt gegner den lauf der geschichte
nicht mehr anhalten können eine
geschichte die allerdings ziemlich
stockt läuft bis ende des jahres muss
ein abkommen mit der eu vorliegen dann
ist die schonfrist abgelaufen
die verhandlungen sollen jetzt wieder in
schwung kommen
doch am kernproblem hat sich nicht viel
geändert großbritannien möchte sich
selbst an keine vorgaben mehr halten
gleichzeitig aber freien zugang zum
europäischen markt haben das wird so
nicht funktionieren und das khroma drama
das sind großbritannien mehr todesopfer
gefordert hat als in jedem anderen
europäischen land macht die lage nicht
besser aus london
andreas ist es gibt eine haar theorie
was boris johnson angeht je zerzauster
desto verzweifelter beim einsamen
rundgang durch ein immer noch
geschlossenes einkaufszentrum gestern
wird klar der grad der verzweiflung
scheint hoch nicht wegen drexhage
johnson verantwortet die meisten corona
toten in europa die wirtschaft so hart
getroffen die kaum einer auf der welt
selbst in den eigenen reihen ist die
rede von totalem regierungsversagen
umfragewerte gehen richtung keller und
keine richtung in sachen drexhage der in
der korona krise nicht mehr chefsache
ist johnson hat ganz andere probleme
johnson ist definitiv in der
schwierigsten lage seit der premier ist
er hat eine wahl schlacht gewonnen mit
dem versprechen ende 2020 komplett aus
der eu zu sein
doch die korona pandemie hat schon
soviel wirtschaftlichen schaden
verursacht kaum zu glauben dass er durch
einen harten weg sieht ohne vertrag noch
mehr schaden zu lassen könnte damit
dass die wirtschaft für johnson doch
zählt die hoffnung derer die kein ende
mit schrecken wollen ein ende der
übergangsphase ohne handelsvertrag
nachdem die briten die gespräche schon
platzen lassen wollten heute beim
videokonferenz- gipfel zuversicht die
kommissionspräsidentin bemüht scheint
ist wo ist er der johnson was will er
denn es ist klar was wir erreichen
wollen so weit sind wir gar nicht
voneinander entfernt in den
verhandlungen braucht es nur ein wenig
booms ihr beruf mehr tiger im tank
ergänzt er typisch johnson viel slogan
wenig substanz im juli soll intensiv
behandelt werden einen kompletten deal
in sechs monaten aushandeln und
ratifizieren des halten handelsexperten
dennoch für schwierig auch wenn eins
klar ist egal ob die oder nicht es wird
auf jeden fall einschneidende
handelshemmnisse an der grenze geben
schadensbegrenzung ist was bleibt man
muss neue arten von kontrollmechanismen
entwickeln aber egal es wird ein harter
brocken aber wenn wir in den herbst
kommen beide seiten sähen einen deal in
reichweite ein paar wochen noch
verhandeln damit es gelingt post johnson
wird dann eine verlängerung nicht
ablehnen mehr zeit vielleicht viel mehr
zeit doch verlängern ist nur anders
nennen die briten selbst die am
pressetag 31 der januar gefeiert haben
sagen mehrheitlich entschieden ja die
korona krise hat prioritäten verschoben
ob der populist johnson der oft nach
umfragewerten regiert das ignoriert
einen wirtschaftlichen doppelschock
kroner plus harter braig sieht riskiert
zerzaust ist er verzweifelt also folgt
man der hna theorie
leider weiß niemand was das für den bhc
rexit heißt der eu gesehen anne gellinek
wie sie jetzt eigentlich die stimmung in
brüssel bei diesem thema es wird ja so
ein bisschen wie täglich grüßt das
murmeltier und endlich wurde das doch
alles schon x-mal durchgekaut
ja das stimmt und trotzdem hat das
treffen heute eine gewisse klarheit
gebracht wo es johnson hat zwar
hinterher wie es seine art ist
vollmundig verkündet man werde sich noch
im juli mit der eu auf ein
freihandelsabkommen einigen
gleichzeitig hat er aber alle roten
linien wiederholt die genau das
verhindern
es gibt ein grundlegendes
missverständnis in den verhandlungen
zwischen london und brüssel
und das lautet dass die briten
kompromisse machen müssen für den zugang
zum binnenmarkt dass diese kompromisse
von der jetzigen britischen regierung
aber eingeschätzt werden als
einschränkung ihrer britischen
souveränität und solange das so ist wird
man sich nicht einigen können und diese
erkenntnis ist vielleicht heute das was
man je der chefunterhändler der eu
letzte woche gemeint hat als er gesagt
hat man komme dem moment der wahrheit
jetzt ein bisschen näher kommen müssten
weitergehen mit diesem moment der
wahrheit also man pokert bis zum schluss
und dann auf den letzten drücker gibt es
eine art vollbremsung kurz vom hafen
ausstieg also hier in brüssel geht man
auf jeden fall davon aus dass boris
johnson bis zur letzten minute pokern
wird man schließt aber auch nicht aus
dass er in letzter minute bei einem
dramatischen gipfel im oktober oder
november
die roten linien selbst wieder
ausradiert die er auf die wand gemalt
hat und eben doch zugeständnisse macht
andererseits bleibt die eu hart sie sagt
sie müsse den eu binnenmarkt für die
anderen 27 mitgliedstaaten schützen und
deshalb bereitet sie sich auch auf das
andere szenario vor dass nämlich wäre
dass die briten am 31 dezember ohne dir
ganz ohne vertrag endgültig aus der eu
ausscheiden dankeschön eine für diese
einschätzung aus bous dass die korona
krise enorm viel geld kosten wird ist
klar und jetzt wird noch etwas klarer
wie viel geld
insgesamt plant die bundesregierung für
dieses jahr eine neuverschuldung von
218,5 milliarden euro das ist so viel
wie noch nie zuvor und fast fünf mal so
viel wie im bisherigen rekord schulden
jahr in der finanzkrise 2010
finanzminister scholz hat einen entwurf
für einen zweiten nachtragshaushalt von
62,5 milliarden euro vorgelegt
zusätzlich zu den bereits bewilligten
nachtrags etat von 156 milliarden
kabinett und bundestag müssen den neuen
krediten zustimmen nach sechs jahren
schwarze null wird damit die
schuldenbremse erneut außer kraft
gesetzt
für studierende die wegen der krise in
finanzieller not sind stellt der bund
hilfen von insgesamt 100 millionen euro
zur verfügung online zu beantragen ab
morgen 12 uhr auf der internetseite
überbrückungshilfe studierende de bis zu
500 euro pro monat für juni bis august
jeweils monatlich neu zu beantragen gibt
es zurückgezahlt werden muss das geld
nicht aber kontoauszüge sind offen zu
legen
die opposition kritisiert das sei zu
wenig und zu spät
der bei einem polizeieinsatz in der
us-großstadt atlanta getötete afro
amerikaner richard brooks ist durch zwei
schüsse in den rücken gestorben das hat
die untersuchung der gerichtsmedizin
ergeben
erneut demonstrierten hunderte menschen
in atlanta in der vergangenen nacht
gegen rassismus und polizeigewalt
brooks hatte sich am freitagabend einer
festnahme widersetzt dabei den beamten
einen taser entwendet und diesen auf die
beamten gerichtet daraufhin schoss einer
der polizisten auf den flüchtenden mann
der 27 jährige starb später im
krankenhaus
ein russisches gericht hat einen us
bürger wegen spionage zu 16 jahren
lagerhaft verurteilt der 50-jährige
polen war vor anderthalb jahren in
moskau verhaftet worden
er soll nach auffassung der richter auf
frischer tat ertappt worden sein als er
einen
usb stick mit geheimen daten erhalten
habe der ehemalige us-soldat bestreitet
die vorwürfe
die us regierung reagierte empört auf
das urteil und fordert die sofortige
freilassung elends wenn sich die
heimattreue deutsche jugend kurz hdj
traf mag das von weiter nach
pfadfinderlager ausgesehen haben
tatsächlich waren das nach beschreibung
und ehemaliger teilnehmer unverblümten
ab sie treffen auf denen man sich mit
heil dir begrüßte inzwischen ist die
organisation verboten
ihre mitglieder sind aber nicht
verschwunden der bisherige brandenburger
afg chef andreas kalbitz etwa war dort
unterwegs er selbst behauptet er habe
sich da nur mal umgeschaut
für dieses lose umschauen truppe aber
wie fotos zeigen schon die richtige
zunft inklusive kurzer lederhose die
dort für männer quasi teil einer uniform
war es sind diese verbindungen die im
parteiinternen machtkampf der afg
zuletzt eine rolle spielten wobei sich
teile des parteivorstands da weniger an
inhalten als an formalien zu stören
scheint
was aber wohl auf jeden fall stört dass
der verfassungsschutz jetzt auch den
gesamten brandenburger landesverband zum
verdachtsfall erklärt hat jan meyer
richtig es war ihr bisher größter
triumph bei der landtagswahl im
vergangenen jahr holte die afg
brandenburgs über 23 prozent der stimmen
keine zehn monate später stuft der
verfassungsschutz den gesamten
landesverband als rechtsextrem 1
die brandenburger fdp hat sich seit
ihrer gründung stetig radikalisiert und
wird mittlerweile von bestrebungen
dominiert die ganz eindeutig gegen
unsere freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung gerichtet sind
der rückhalt für den rechtsaußen andreas
kalbitz ist groß trotz seines rauswurfs
aus der partei durch den bundesvorstand
der einfluss des volkes
nationalistischen flügels ist
ungebrochen
erst ende april dieses jahres für
aufgelöst erklärte flügel konnte und
kann in brandenburg aufgrund seiner
breiten basis und seines einflusses
praktisch nicht vom rest der partei
getrennt beobachtet werden
partei und fraktion sind eng vernetzt
mit anderen rechtsextremen
organisationen besonders im süden
brandenburgs der verein zukunft heimat
organisiert in cottbus flüchtlings
feindliche demonstrationen und steht
seit januar unter beobachtung ihr
vorsitzender sitzt als abgeordneter im
landtag
die brandenburger fd ist geprägt von
einem kulturellen volks bild das
menschen anderer herkunft oder religion
verächtlich macht und somit gegen die
würde des menschen verstößt nach dem
thüringer ist damit nun der zweite
landesverband der afg offiziell ein
rechtsextremer verdachtsfall die
kritisiert die beobachtung durch den
verfassungsschutz als falsch ist für uns
ein erwartbares politisches manöver des
instrumentalisierten verfassungsschutzes
unserer partei die salamitaktik rückt
man bedient jedes monat neues bundesland
was man unter verdacht stellen möchte
einige experten dagegen halten sogar
eine beobachtung der gesamten afd für
überfällig der ft suggeriert seit jahren
sie sei eine bürgerliche national
konservative kraft aber sie hat die
grundsatzentscheidung sich wirklich vom
rechtsextremismus zu distanzieren nie
vollzogen
und das fällt jetzt auf die füße der
verfassungsschutz kann nun die
brandenburger fd mit v männern und
anderen nachrichtendienstlichen mitteln
überwachen
der landesverband der partei hat am
abend angekündigt dagegen klage
einzureichen wenn man sein unternehmen
augustus nennt fragt man offenbar großes
vor jedenfalls wenn der firmenname an
den römischen kaiser augustus erinnern
soll
semantisch würde das ja durchaus zu karl
theodor zu guttenberg kassen
august los erinnerte an gutenbergs
berühmt gewordene formulierung vom
kairos auch wenn das griechische ist und
nicht getan den kairos sprich den
günstigen moment scheint augustus bisher
geschäftlich zwar noch nicht gefunden zu
haben
dafür aber interessante kontakte neben
dem ehemaligen deutschen
verteidigungsminister gehören dazu laut
medienberichten auch ehemalige deutsche
geheimdienstler die hans-georg maßen und
august hanning
nun sind das überwiegend ehemalige
neudeutsch des beats aber daneben steht
noch eine zukunftshoffnung der cdu
philipp am tor der gerne auch als jung
star der partei bezeichnet wird
für ihn ist die augustus verbindung nun
genau das gegenteil des kairos
denn einen schlechteren moment für diese
berichte hätte es kaum geben können
berichten patricia wieder meyer und
britta buchholz
bislang galt er als christdemokratische
hoffnungsträger als strebsamer vorzeige
konservativer philipp am tor der
musterschüler der cdu der 27 jährige
bundestagsabgeordnete will
cdu-vorsitzender in mecklenburg
vorpommern werden möglicherweise gar
ministerpräsident doch seine tätigkeit
für eine us firma könnte ihm nun zum
verhängnis werden
zwar hat mit dem briefpapier des
bundestages lobby termine vereinbart im
wird bundeswirtschaftsministerium war
dann da selber auch zugegen hat dann
hinterher anteils optionen
direktorenposten bekommen bei der firma
der brief ging wohl vorher auch in der
firma rom das kann sich ruhig eine
staatsanwaltschaft einmal anschauen ob
hier nicht ein anfangsverdacht auf
mandatsträger bestechung vorliegt
am tor hatte im herbst 2008 10 für die
amerikanische firma augustus
intelligence bei wirtschaftsminister
altmaier um politische unterstützung
geworben obwohl er im aufsichtsrat saß
und aktienoptionen des start ups hatte
zudem arbeitet er wieder selber
offenlegt als freier mitarbeiter für die
us-wirtschaft kanzlei white & case das
wirft fragen auf kanzleien sind oft
einfallstor für lobbyismus die cdu hüllt
sich in schweigen nur einer spricht
offen aus was wohl viele in der partei
denken amthor glaube ich muss selber zum
beispiel noch erklären wer hat die
flugreisende zahl für die übernachtung
bezahlt welche größenordnung hat das ist
ein junger mann das war nicht gerade
klug und clever was er da gemacht hat am
tor selber räumte inzwischen ein es sei
ein fehler gewesen er sei nicht käuflich
habe sich aber politisch angreifbar
gemacht für die opposition reicht das
nicht
mich zeigt sich natürlich an diesem
jungen talent philipp abend sehr wohl da
der verdacht der käuflichkeit das sollte
wirklich jetzt auch unter überprüft
werden auch vom bundestagspräsidium der
fall am tor ist ein weckruf an die den
gesamten bundestag jetzt endlich
wirklich transparenz herzustellen wir
kaufen einen entschiedenen kampf gegen
lobbyismus wir brauchen also ein
lobbyregister doch alle versuche solch
ein verbindliches lobby-register
einzuführen scheiterten bisher
opposition und spd fordern erneut mehr
transparenz im grenzbereich zwischen
politik und lobbyismus
beschäftigungsverhältnis zu der firma
steht um die es geht und ein
lobbyregister bedeutet auch dass alle
interessensvertreter die dafür bezahlt
werden in einem register sich melden
müssen und hinterlegt werden muss man
sie mit welchen abgeordneten gesprochen
haben die bundestagsverwaltung soll so
ist zu hören jetzt philipp am tours
geschäftsreisen überprüfen haben freitag
will sein landesverband beraten wie es
mit dem bisherigen hoffnungsträger
amthor weitergeht
nun zu einer unternehmerischen
erfolgsgeschichte wer impfstoffe
entwickelt bietet in diesen zeiten das
wohl weltweit begehrteste produkt auch
wenn noch unklar ist wie gut es am ende
sein wird aber mit dem thema
bundesweiter weltweiten rennen um einen
impfstoff gegen des corona virus hat
sich die bundesregierung das tübinger
biotech-unternehmen kovac ausgesucht um
sich vorteile zu sichern mit 300
millionen euro steigt der bund erstmals
in die branche ein in der viele an der
entwicklung eines impfstoffs arbeiten
frank bethmann
was hat für den bund den ausschlag
gegeben sich da führt ihr weg zu
entscheiden ja das sei eben eines jener
unternehmen das durch seine technologie
und forschung so wichtig sei dass so
viel potenzial habe dass man kirberg
eben auch mit diesem millionen
engagement finanzielle sicherheit bieten
wolle
damit es weiter an impfstoffen arbeiten
kann auf der gemeinsamen pressekonferenz
mit haupteigentümer und sap gründer
dietmar hopp sprach
bundeswirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
heute ganz offen von der hohen
industriepolitischen bedeutung des
unternehmens mehr noch das investment in
die biotech firma sei auch als schutz
vor dem einstieg ausländischer
investoren zu verstehen
wir verkaufen unser tafelsilber nicht
stellte altmaier klar
angeblich hatte sich us-präsident trank
die forschungsergebnisse der tübinger
exklusiv sichern wollen
der wettlauf um einen wirksamen
impfstoff ist nicht nur ein wettlauf
gegen das virus es ist auch eine um das
ganz große geld weit über 100
unternehmen und einrichtungen forschen
daran darunter einige wie biontech aus
deutschland die französische sanofi die
britische astrazeneca oder moderner aus
den usa den experten allesamt sogar
einen vorsprung bescheinigen
zeitgleich zum einstieg des bundes gab
jobbik heute im übrigen noch etwas
anderes bekannt seinen börsengang im
kommenden monat an der nasdaq in den usa
was den rückschluss zulässt dass 300
millionen allein offenbar nicht reichen
um das wettrennen zu gewinnen vielen
dank
us-präsident traum hat gerade eben vor
wenigen minuten angekündigt die in
deutschland stationierten truppen der
usa von über 34.000 man auf 25.000 zu
reduzieren
solange deutschland nicht bereit sei die
verteidigungsausgaben zu erhöhen würden
die usa den plan umsetzen und ihre
truppen zurückziehen
trump beschwerte sich erneut deutschland
gebe zu wenig für die verteidigung aus
nach dem durchzug einer unwetter und
gewitterfront vor allem im nordosten
deutschlands gibt es nun noch eine
unwetterwarnung bis morgen früh muss im
südosten bayerns mit ergiebigem
dauerregen gerechnet werden
starkregen und heftige unwetter hatten
am sonntagabend in vielen teilen
deutschlands zu verkehrsbehinderungen
und überflutungen geführt deren folgen
heute noch zu bewältigen waren besonders
betroffen bayern thüringen und
niedersachsen ortschaften standen unter
wasser wie hier in damme nördlich von
osnabrück bewohner und feuerwehr waren
heute den ganzen tag über mit den
aufräumarbeiten beschäftigt
auf regennassen straßen gab es
zahlreiche unfälle
in thüringen kamen dabei zwei menschen
ums leben
das schöne münchen hat so viel zu
glanzvolle historische gebäude die nähe
zu den alpen der weiß-blaue himmel das
berühmte oktoberfest und nicht zuletzt
auch noch ein tod schickes
fußballstadion vor sein tun
aber eines hat münchen nicht einen
wirklich guten modernen konzertsaal der
akustisch und architektonisch auf
weltniveau ist deshalb soll ein neues
konzerthaus gebaut werden eine art
bayerische elbphilharmonie
doch mit den leidvollen erfahrungen der
hamburger vor augen ahnt man die sache
wird kompliziert aber look berichtet
wie viel ist uns kultur wert und wie
sollte sich wertschätzung in bauten
spiegeln das geplante neue konzerthaus
in münchen eine hochkarätige kathedrale
für heimische und internationale welt
orchester soll es werden angemessen oder
feudaler hochmut in diesen zeiten gerade
in zeiten der krise muss ich doch jeder
die frage stellen habe ich musik gehört
warf musik für mich besonders wichtig
und dann werden wir vielleicht sogar
fast mit schrecken feststellt es geht
gar nicht ohne mit dem geplanten
konzerthaus ist eine alte debatte neu
entflammt passend pompöse kulturbauten
die finanziell zuweilen völlig aus dem
ruder laufen noch in die zeit oder
braucht man sie jetzt mehr denn je
winfried bausback ehemaliger bayerischer
justizminister wagt sich als einziger
aus dem langen schatten der
landesregierung und formuliert seine
bedenken im zuständigen ausschuss und
vor unserer kamera
jetzt hat sich mit der korona pandemie
eine neue situation ergeben und wir
ziehen wir weiter
großprojekte wie das konzerthaus weiter
darstellbar sind also
maß halten doch bayern zeigt nun mal
gerne allen wie es geht
und so soll hier ein gläserner palast
entstehen der es mit nicht weniger als
der welt aufnehmen können
der akustik gott tadeu nakajima
beispielsweise wird mit ausgefeilten
echo kammern für einen strahlenden klang
sorgen und damit das ist jetzt schon
klar mehr platz brauchen
doch zu den offenbar steigenden kosten
wagt derzeit niemand eine schätzung aus
gutem grund ich fürchte das ist ein fass
ohne boden werden wird meines erachtens
nach ist der typisch bayerisch
konservative größenwahn über die
menschen hinweg galoppiert und man kam
dann in den status von hand gesagt hat
man braucht die weltbesten akustiker man
braucht die weltbesten bauten die
weltbesten materialien von größenwahn
überrumpeln lassen ist ganz gefährlich
für öffentliche bauprojekte die in
münchen lebende ann sophie mutter
hingegen fordert weitblick horizont
kunst sei essentiell brauchen visionen
und eben eine entsprechende plattform
musik ist ein geschenk an uns alle und
das wollen die an einem rahmen genießen
der münchen würdig ist der den großen
orchestern die hier beheimatet sind
würdig ist und der uns auch
international ein gastorchester kommen
in dem licht erscheinen lässt indem wir
gesehen werden wollen immer als große
kulturnation wird kultur also lästig
wenn sie viel geld kostet oder steht sie
schlichtweg dafür noch gibt es das
konzerthaus nur im modell und die frage
wird am ende bleiben wie viel ist uns
kultur wert
das war es von uns mit der
thriller-serie mirage gefährliche lügen
geht es jetzt weiter
und gegen mitternacht meldet sich hanna
zimmermann mit heute plus gibt es wieder
ein heute journal
bis dahin noch wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren
nadine und petra bewegen sich kaum von
der stelle aber sie haben es in sich
denn sie sorgen für eine konvergenzzone
zum einen trocken warme und zum anderen
feucht warme luftströme aufeinander zu
und dann hat diese wirft gar keine
andere möglichkeit als aufzusteigen
es entwickeln sich dicke wolken es
kräftige regenfälle und sogar unwetter
heute nacht regnet es ergiebig am
alpenrand im nordosten dagegen ist es
klar und so sinken die temperaturen hier
zwischen nordfriesland und der
lüneburger heide auf acht oder neun grad
sonst bleibt die nacht bei 10 bis 15
grad milder morgen liegen dann die
höchsttemperaturen hier zwischen der
neiße und der schweiz bei sommerlichen
25 bis 27 grad sonst liegen die werte
meist um 20 grad und kühler ist es
eigentlich nur am alpenrand bei 16 grad
denn dort regnet es morgen noch am
längsten
erst nachmittags lassen dort die
regenfälle nach in der gesamten
südwesthälfte gibt's morgen trüben
himmel
immer wieder fällt regen auch gewitter
sind dabei im nordosten dagegen strahlt
die sonne und die hat es wirklich in
sich bei einem uv-index von acht droht
ihnen wenn sie hellhäutig sind
ungeschützt bereits nach 20 minuten in
der sonne ein sonnenbrand also passen
sie bitte auf sie sehen hier sehr schön
wo die konvergenz linie morgen liegt
zwischen dem niederrhein und dem
alpenrand und die zieht in den nächsten
tagen ganz allmählich weiter nach
nordosten
am freitag erreicht sie dann auch die
ostseeküste schönen abend noch